I'm cake with a multi-level point
scientific continue group I'm will be
talking about neuroscience in the
Wolfram language plays our ongoing
effort to add more data contents in
medicine the life science area and
neuroscience one the subject area
we just wanted to care cover as they are
growing interests in among students in
brain and cognition
warum alpha developer in scientific
content group there are many ways in
Mathematica to work work with
neuroscience data ranging from
processing images and signals to
analyzing temporal data and network
graphs in this talk we are specifically
looking at data that had been added to
warm knowledgebase to demonstrate how we
could analyze and illustrate the
structure and function of the human
nervous system all in the warm language
and also it's part of our ongoing effort
to expand this knowledge base in sign
life science and medicine areas as
they're growing interest especially
among students in those subject areas so
with the new introduced set of data we
can access information on brain anatomy
neuron characteristics and cognitive map
and forced to set up data describe the
structure of human nervous system and
the last one illustrates the functional
aspect of the human nervous system so
studying up by adrenaline to me the
brain is the center part of the nervous
system and the physical map or address
of the brain and network connectivity
give us information about how our brain
is wired in the nervous system and our
human brain contains about 100 billions
of neurons and of course it's not an
easy job to identify all of those brain
cells characteristics of a few hundred
neurons were identified already
for instance physical and spiking
characteristics and those defined
processing ability of the network and
some students in research with fMRI we
can that
localized brain activity where we
process a specific cognitive function
and that allow us to create a like
statistical cognitive map of brain
activities so we are looking at examples
some examples for each of these so
starting off by brain anatomy we have
expanded existing an intermediate to
include more detailed brains regional
anatomy brain anatomy information and
our data is based on umls and neural
legs both legs come type database and
the last one body parts 3d provides our
graphics 3d models and just to remind
you again all of the data and examples
I'm going to show you it's available
through our entity framework so we have
over 3,000 entities to describe brain
structures ranging from large cortical
areas to smaller nucleus that
constitutes the larger part of the brain
and we have now over 120 properties to
describe or accessing more information
about individual structures
some are image properties graphics and
geometric properties and some describes
the connectivity or physical
characteristics and among those some
properties are especially dedicated to
explore new anatomy and with
combinations of these entities and
properties we can take a more closer
look at individual structure individual
brain structures for example by
accessing image properties of anatomy
later we can visualize a structure
viewed from different perspectives so
this is looking at large cortical area
prefrontal cortex
or we can label and also color each sub
part of the structure using Anatomy plot
3d function and of course we can also
ask warm alpha to get more information
or example what's the function of the
prefrontal cortex and get normalized
anatomical functional concept
decision-making in this case and there
are many ways to separate brain years in
smaller regions based on structural
characteristics and Broadman urea is one
of the classical categorizations to
separate grainy areas based on site
architecture and we can highlight the
area of your interest or use additional
properties to get more information for
example we can get neighboring
structures or find what larger systemic
brain but it this structure is part of
and moving to even smaller structure for
example we can find the area one of the
areas with the brain associated with
that in cause emotional state and one is
amygdala which is the primal part of the
brain and has key roles in emotional
response memory and recognition
associated with memory emotions so once
again we can visualize the structure
using Anatomy plot 3d function and
amygdala is located near the center of
the brain and shape and size it's just
like an almond and taking this amygdalas
on as an example we can now take a look
at brains wiring
we have neuronal connectivity
information which includes more than
1,500 input-output connectivity
relations across different brain areas
for example you can find output areas of
amygdala there and we can also visualize
the network using the Browse function
and this is the amygdala and this these
are the direct output areas and the
additional graph functionality in
Mathematica
help us analyze the network and find the
finding feedback loop is one example
which is the kief framework in any
biological network to fine tune the
system by altering the signal
transmission so for example we can find
highlight the loops involving involved
amygdala and other areas for example
ceramic nucleus our next example we can
find specific circuits that involves
particular structures here we are
finding a circuit that involves amygdala
and prefrontal cortex and the highlight
in the graph and as you remember
prefrontal cortex functions in
decision-making so this circuit is
crucial for motivating response to
emotional experiences
and of course we can find more than one
circuits or loops in the network but
I'll just for the demonstration purpose
I only showed two layers of the network
also the signals from the brain
eventually reach the spinal cord to
excite motor response and sometimes
network needs shortcut pathway to
execute execute the command that's
quickly as possible for example to
escape from the threatening object and
so minimum cost flow might be one of the
ways to point those shortcut pathways
with number amygdala to spinal cord and
not limited to brain central network we
have also information about more
peripheral nerve pathways this is the
example of visual perception pathway and
we can visualize them the light signal
comes into the eye and signal travels
optic nerve crossing optic chasm and
reaches the visual area in hospital lobe
and brain integrates the input with
other information and send command back
to periphery for motor response so for
example we can find nerves innervating
in your left hand and visualize those
nerves
so now let's take a look at even smaller
components of the brain brains
functional unit a neuron now we have an
information on over 300 types of neurons
based on neural legs and the neuro
electrode database and this is the
morphology of a typical neuron this is
the soma over neuron that contains cell
body and these branches are the
dendrites that where the signals come in
so input areas and the signals travel
down the axon and reached axon terminals
and where it makes synaptic connections
with other neurons so it passes the
signal to other areas of the brain and
we have study three properties to
describe physical and spatial
characteristics of neuron different
types of neurons and some are about
absence specific properties for example
origin of action links or soma diameter
somewhere about dendrite number of
dendrites and then right location and so
on and one of the important
characteristics of the neuron is type of
chemicals released from the cell called
neurotransmitter for example we can find
neurotransmitter released from one of
the protein G cell of a serum and if you
like to know more about this chemical
you can also access our chemical data to
get more information and other types of
properties describe the location of the
cell or reversely you can ask what
happened iran tsar found in the given
non-atomic of structure so retina
contains various type of neurons
including light-sensitive photoreceptor
cells or even more specifically we can
find what type of neurons
extends axon in particular area as an
auditory cortex and neurons use
electrical signals to communicate with
other neurons and the researchers
typically record the electrical spike
activity called action potentials to
identify the type and signal type and
structure of the signal transmission and
of course they can use our signal
processing functionality to sort out
spikes and analyze their data and we
have some characteristics properties to
describe those electrophysiological
characteristics of those spiking
activities or action potentials some
important characteristics amplitude
withers was threshold of the spikes and
we can take a look at spike frequency of
various types of neurons and we can see
how some neurons are first while a
firing was a summer slow empowering and
these variations defined the processing
ability of the network and this is just
a small excursion from the main topic
but we can also model spike neurons
Mathematica is fully equipped with
solving differential equations so we can
take advantage of that and the model
spike activities are using
hodgkin-huxley model there are number of
variations in hodgkin-huxley models and
some allows to simulate the propagation
of spike activities from preparation of
neurons and we can easily change the
parameters to find find the best fit
model for the biologically plausible is
very plausible spiking neurons
so finally after looking at smallest
components of the brain let's take a
look at brains cognitive function
variety of cognitive process that takes
place in the brain can be categorized
and hierarchically mapped we have over
800 concepts from cognitive address
database to describe brains community
function and some properties are
available to get more information about
individual concepts for example
definition associated anatomical site
and some hierarchical relationships and
by looking at these hierarchical
relationships how we can illustrate how
some of our fundamental cognitive
functions for example decision-making
memory and perception related to one
another example here memory perception
and decision-making are highlighted here
and it's connected for example
perception especially auditory
perception and here a memory recognition
meet here for tone recognition or here
face recognition and from
decision-making social inference meet
here for facial trust was in its
recognition and sometimes the other type
of visualization helped us gain some
more insights and this is looking at the
same relations but with using community
graph plot group of concepts here
describe the perception and here
constitute the memory and this
constituted decision-making so there or
meet here in the middle for recognition
of object face and
dance we can also relate to this to
structural parts of the brain whenever
we can find the cognitive concepts
associated with each cerebral lobe of
the brain and find a simple create a
simple map like this example frontal
lobe functions in motor control
decision-making and so on but this is
just an abstract representation of the
brain function but now we can take a
look at more detailed training
activities we have fMRI is powerful tool
to detect subtle change in brain
activities and we have statistical maps
of brain activity from database called
neuro board and which is based on meta
analysis or task based fMRI so this is
the original data
it's a boxer data and we converted these
to graphics and also aligned to the
coordinate system used in anatomy data
for example this is looking at brain
images coronary sliced from front to the
back during decision-making processing
oh we can spot a high activity area near
the top surface of the brain so how did
damage it is there are standard
experimental tasks to assess those who
need certain cognitive abilities for
example these are the tasks to measure
decision-making ability and if you're
not familiar with those tasks we have
also basically information about each
task and of course you can use our
interface functionality to build your
own task set just for some fun
and this is I was a gambling task to
major decision-making or image
recognition test to assess visual object
recognition ability but these are just
some examples to assess community by
bility so more examples of brain
activity we have a resume attic
processing our mass or calculation
ability involves parietal lobe of the
brain indicated by these high activity
areas and next one is a language
processing we can also make an image
collage with just a simple line of code
this is looking at brain from the front
and this is our corner slice horizontal
slice from top to bottom and such third
slice is from right to left and in most
people along each area is located in the
left side of the brain and next one is
emotion processing we can spot a higher
activity area near the center of the
brain
perhaps this shows your memory this is
amygdala and this activity area is
available in the form of 3d graphics and
can be extracted so it's a rotatable TV
activation area associated with emotion
so we can combine this graphic with
other brain structure now there is not a
mediator to for example have get
graphics overlay or do some geometric
computations to actually calculate the
graphics intersections
so finally these graphics
combined the hierarchical organization
of the cognitive concept with brain
activities and this top is the visual
perception and we are looking at child
concepts and it's interesting to see how
Calabrian categorize visually perceive
it plays pattern or number string with
all distinctive patterns of activities
so now I'd like to take a moment to
summarize my talk with our newest
introduced set of data a Virgo in Warren
language provide us information about
new brain's anatomy and neuron
characteristics and statistical
cognitive Maps and neural Anatomy color
divided areas
described the structure and function of
the nervous system and the
connectivities across those brain areas
can be characterized and visualized and
of course additional from graph
functionality Mathematica help us
analyze the network and also we have
information about individual types of
neurons and those can be characterized
for spike analysis and finally we also
have statistical maps of brain activity
to illustrate or visualize the brain
activity associated with cognitive
function and those can be for the
processed or extracted for the graphics
computation so what's coming next we are
expecting to add more information about
individual brain circuits and sensory
motor pathways and as you might heard
about it they are ongoing human
connectome map project where they are
looking at connectivities in fiber
levels so there are more to be
discovered and data to be expanded in
near future also you know we welcome any
suggest
or requests for the addition in
computational neuroscience area so
that's all I hope No thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah
so another mediator has associated with
disease calls like properties to
describe what like diseases are
associated with individual logical
structures but we don't have anything
about more detail pathology just you
know what disease are associated here a
certain area of the brain were certain
structures in the body are not limited
to brain
yes yeah thank you
yeah
which means yeah yeah yeah actually we
are looking at other species actually we
have some plans about ink yeah I have
actually
yeah this is another project we have
animal on a three project so we have
plans of having some structures and
different species yeah this side project
yeah yes right yes I heard about it it
is yeah I think so we have like go equip
it with all our interface functionality
so it's I think possible but it's just
not in our entity framework but I think
it's possible yes we have our models of
peripheral nervous system so but because
it's not complete some moves smaller
nervous system missing but we have a
large number of peripheral nerves so for
example so this one is looking at large
major nerves innervating the hand or arm
yeah yeah yeah that's something we don't
have those data yet but I think that's
yeah something okay so we can just but
yeah yeah yeah yes yeah yeah that's
right yeah it's only like for them this
is male adult models of course there are
variations in males versus females and
also children versus adults so that's
something we have to address yeah
many of the quantitative data about
pollutants what that was a technical
factors
thank you
[Applause]